il ya eu des premières alertes et il y a
eu un système j'ai envie de dire de
suivi d'épidémies qui est très tôt mis
en place dès le début janvier on est
dans la routine classique on active un
certain nombre de mesures de
surveillance de vigilance au sein du
ministère de la santé pour le suivi très
sérieux de cette épidémie
de ce point de vue là on a cru mais on
n'active pas le plan de kameni grippal
ont fait l'hypothèse pour la raison
principale que le plan de pandémie
grippale ça oblige à mettre dans le jeu
un organe qui a été prévu pour la
gestion de ce type de crise qui est la
cellule interministérielle de crise et
la cellule interministérielle de crise
elle fait remonter à la table des
discussions et de la décision un
ensemble d'âge ans de ministère dont le
ministère de l'intérieur que
certainement emmanuel macron edouard
philippe et olivier ferrand ne voulait
pas voir rentrer dans le jeu de la
discussion et là on a quelque chose qui
est certainement l'expression et la
manifestation de d'un mode de
fonctionnement de de ce gouvernement qui
se méfie de ces administrations
la tempête qui a eu lieu deux ans
auparavant a été très mal gérée dans les
îles a été très mal gérée par la
sécurité civile il ya beaucoup de
reproches qu'on ferme notamment par
rapport la sécurité civile qui dépend du
ministère de l'intérieur et nous on y
voit vraiment la volonté pour le
président le premier ministre et le
ministre de la santé de s'octroyer une
capacité de décision autonome 1 sans
avoir à faire monter à la table des
négociations
des agences des administrations qui ont
leur intérêt leur culture qui parfois
sont en conflit entre elles donc de ce
point de vue là il ya vraiment eu une
gestion qu'on pourrait dire élitaire des
grandes décisions de lacq city
[Musique]